good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-1128
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
written descriptions or imagery of
scp-1128's appearance or videos of the
entity breaching see addendum 1128-3
found outside the foundation are to be
destroyed and class-c amnestics are to
be administered to anyone exposed to
such information or showing signs of
scp-1128 contamination a written
description of the entity's appearance
is to be kept at site
for experimental purposes only and is
not to be read by anyone other than
d-class used for testing
if exposed staff are to report
immediately for administration of class
c amnestics mobile containment force
kappa 12 has been assigned to intercept
and redirect any and all water traffic
that passes through their designated
patrol area by any means necessary see
addendum 1128 to
description
scp-1128 is an entity that manifests as
a massive aquatic predator to anyone
given a full description of the being's
appearance through either spoken or
written descriptions or visual
depictions of the being persons infected
by scp-1128 will initially exhibit no
abnormal behavior though some cases show
general aversion to activities involving
bodily immersion in water such as
bathing or swimming should the subject
ever be fully immersed in water they
will disappear completely under the
surface of the water regardless of the
water's actual depth in most cases
subjects will reappear moments later in
a panicked state and frantically try to
leave the water while in some other
cases water will become polluted with
blood and debris confirmed to be the
remains of the subject subjects that
have reappeared intact claim that they
were transported to a vast ocean where
they are pursued by
scp-1128 interviews with these
individuals carries some risk of further
scp-1128 contamination as descriptions
of the being's appearance trigger
further infections
scp-1128 infection can be treated with
class c amnestics as it appears memory
of the entity or descriptions of it are
required for its anomalous properties to
take effect
addendum 1128 1
testing with infected d-class have shown
that wireless communication devices
function normally when used by submerged
subjects affected by
scp-1128 see interview 112804
for details
this is interview 1128.04
interview
1128.04
interviewed d 1645
interviewer dr stevens
forward d 1645 was instructed to read
from a small pamphlet describing
scp-1128's appearance then was outfitted
with diving gear and lowered into a
large tub of water via a winch and cable
the 1645's gear was outfitted with a
wireless communication device to allow
contact between himself and dr stevens
and detest if the scp had any effect on
such devices interview has been edited
to remove hazardous information
pertaining to scp-1128
begin log
d-1645 can you hear me over i hear you
doc
damn this thing is deep it looks so tiny
from outside
how well is your reception over it's
good enough i guess it's kind of fuzzy
but i don't know if i can't hear what
you're saying
what is your current status
right now i'm just sinking to the bottom
of
this this the ocean how did you manage
to fit an entire ocean inside a stinkin
bathtub irrelevant d-1645
what are your surroundings
i just said ocean damn it there's fish
in everything don't you guys know what
the hell's inside your own thing
d-1645 what happened
i'm fine i'm fine i just hit the bottom
looks like i've landed on a patch of
seaweed or something what are your
surroundings uh seaweed mostly
wait a second it gets thinner to my
right looks like there might be a drop
off that way should i go take a look
you may
proceed
damn suit's heavy it's hard to move in
this thing
hey is this thing soundproof i hope my
talking isn't scaring off any oh my god
d-1645
d-1645 respond what is your status
i'm okay
i'm okay i don't think it saw me
damn i think i pissed myself what
happened what did you see
scariest damn thing i ever seen
some kind of big ass
wait a second that's the thing from that
booklet you gave me isn't it affirmative
please refrain from describing it any
further what is it doing
nothing right now it's
it's just swimming along
i think it's got something in its mouth
is it a whale
holy crap it is it's eating a whale
oh god look at those teeth
i think we're done here pull him out now
thank you for your cooperation we're
bringing you up now and now we swallowed
it
damn the thing is gonna haunt my dreams
wait it's stopped moving
i i think it sees me
oh god it's looking right at me it's
headed this way oh god help me get him
out of there now
end lock
closing statement
winch was retracting at full speed when
the cable went taut wrestling the winch
from its mounting cable then went slack
and water became polluted with blood
confirmed to be that of d1645
no further remains or equipment were
recovered interview logs and relevant
documents were edited for vectors and
all staff present were treated with
class c amnestics
addendum 1128 2
tracking devices affixed to d-class used
in scp-1128 experiments reveal that
submerged subjects are transported to an
area within the pacific ocean not far
from the coast
further investigation of these
coordinates revealed the area to be
mobile containment force kappa 12 sea
devils has been assigned to keep
unauthorized seafaring vessels out of
this area at all costs
note that's where we've been sending
those d-class how does a short-range
wireless communicator get such a clear
signal from that far away
dr stevens
addendum 1128 3
tests involving d1732
who had been used for repeated scp-1128
testing without administration of
amnestics was shown to be able to
encounter the entity in bodies of water
normally insufficient for bodily
immersion this effect became more
drastic over time with d1732 developing
progressively stronger hydrophobic
tendencies claiming to see scp-1128 from
outside almost any body of water
encountered by the subject on an
undisclosed date 10 days after initial
exposure
d-1732 was violently pulled into a glass
of water but
no remains were recovered from the
incident staff witnessing the event were
found to be infected by scp-1128
and administered class c amnestics
containment procedures were then updated
to include videos and descriptions of
this event and testing involving
extended infection of d-class was
terminated
experiment log 1128
experiment log 1128 a1
date unknown
procedure d-class exposed to scp-1128
outfitted with diving gear and
communication device then lowered into
tub of water
result see interview 1128.04
experiment log 1128 a2
date unknown
procedure d-class exposed to
scp-1128 and equipped with scuba gear
placed into a standard protective shark
cage and lowered into water
result no response for approximately
nine seconds then line went taut and was
severed at the point beneath the water
remains of d-class as well as jagged
steel fragments presumably remnants of
the cage surfaced shortly afterward
experiment log 1128 a3
date unknown
procedure same as previous cage treated
with scp
to increase durability
result same as previous no remains
surfaced
notes 12 hours later mcfc devils
reported finding an intact shark cage
floating beneath the surface of a patrol
area near one of their vessels item was
retrieved and confirmed to match
description of cage used in experiment
1128 a3 cage was undamaged but bore
traces of human dna and feces of
indeterminate origin no further remains
of d-class found
experiment log 1128 a4
date unknown procedure exposed d-class
equipped with diving gear and armed with
for use against hostile organisms unlike
previous tests the subject was also
equipped with a live feed video camera
attached to his helmet
result video feed shows weapon was
ineffective against
scp-1128 appearing only to enrage the
creature rather than harm it
considerably or drive it away feed was
lost when d-class was devoured staff
involved were treated with amnestics
following transcription of the video
feed
experiment log 1128 a5
date unknown
procedure exposed d-class equipped with
protective environment suit and video
feed lowered into vative
to test scp-1128 manifestation in
liquids other than water substance
chosen for its low density allowing free
movement similar to walking in open air
result d-class recovered without
incident liquid did not trigger
scp-1128's effect
note
okay so you might be safe from the thing
in liquids other than water but that
probably won't help you much unless you
intend to drink and bathe in exotic
chemicals for the rest of your life
which would probably get a lot shorter
if you tried that
dr palmer
okay this concludes today's lecture
don't forget your class c amnestics on
the way out
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
jos truvoca
or in peace
treon
zargara
professor puffer
retalias
jk
segnar
your local fishman
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nath decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
hms lily
the almighty fish
scio dio demnatus
eric corbinge
longinus
the morrigan
caramel ashmuy
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you